foreign
this country which punches far above its
weight in so many areas has
underachieved terribly when it comes to
technology
for years talented Aussie coders have
escaped to Silicon Valley to make their
livings and recent Australian government
policies have underfunded Science and
Tech as my Pap would say
Aussie Tech is crook
being here there are signs though that
Australia has turned on and started to
retain some of its homegrown Tech Talent
[Music]
this then is an odyssey to find the
country's Rising Stars
my journey goes from the beaches of
Sydney to The Artsy Cosmopolitan streets
of Melbourne along the way I get lost in
a cave with only glow worms to guide me
go fishing with an internet Playboy and
make friends with some dinosaurs
foreign
[Applause]
check any survey of the best places to
live and you'll find Sydney near the top
[Music]
it's a sprawling gorgeous city of about
4 million good-spirited people who love
to be outdoors
to party and to enjoy life
but there's a strong case to be made
that Sydney ciders may be too content
at least when it comes to the city's
Tech scene
well big companies like Google and
Microsoft have Offices here
Sydney can only point to a couple of
Smash startups that have made it big
overseas
that famous Aussie pluck has gone
missing
there is however a tech Revolution
building and it's being led by Young
ambitious scientists
they've left their fancy University labs
and migrated to Sydney's Tech
Underground
and no one proves this point more than
the free radical I'll meet first
okay this spot doesn't exactly ooze Tech
it's an artist Warehouse in a Sydney
suburb
but moved deeper through the creative
commune and you'll find a makeshift
science lab and this guy one of its
Founders A transhumanist polyamorous
biohacker
you all know the type
welcome to bio Foundry Australia's First
Open Access molecular biology lab
sinisters it can sometimes sound
biohacking has turned into an exciting
New Field
do it yourself meddling with DNA on the
cheap to tweak nature and this is
Australia's first biohacker lab open to
anyone willing to pay a membership fee
let's get into it
[Music]
and the name of this biohacking pioneer
meow meow do you prefer to be a Mr meow
Mr meow meow
meows meows fine
meow hit up Jenner's friends for a lot
of the scientific gear and he hopes the
lab will inspire people of all Stripes
to give biotech a try
it's about pulling people in with
Hands-On experiments like extracting DNA
from the strawberry
if you stir away the alcohol touches the
strawberries you'll be able to pull out
some stringy stuff and that's the DNA so
that's the instructions to make a
strawberry
this is the first step in a biohack lab
pretty much anything we're doing with
molecular biology we're going to need to
get that DNA out the flavor genes the
pigment genes we can take these genes
out and put them in other things so you
might want to make an apple that tastes
like a strawberry you might be able to
uh take the pigment genes out and make a
new type of paint so you kind of take
the most interesting properties of some
organism extracted out and then maybe
Chuck it into something else and give it
some new superpowers that's it yeah make
everything glow
the molecular biologist by training meow
has put the lab to work on real projects
ranging from anti-mold paint and
take-home STD tests to phosphorus and
alcohol
cool
demonstrated is
this place in nature
we set out for the Nuna state forest
located in the famed Blue Mountains
about five hours West of Sydney it's
there that we hope to find the tiny
creature at the heart of meows make
everything feel like a rave dreams so
we're about to go to the glow worm
tunnel it used to be a railway tunnel
they used in mining and now it's been
decommissioned and the glowworms have
come back and reinhabited the the tunnel
I've waited this long and now I have to
ask you how did you get the name meow
meow
I'd wanted to change my name since I was
like 15. my friends and I just sat down
and we just wrote down a huge list of
names and then we picked the one that
sounded the best
what's your full name now meow Ludo
disco gamma meow meow
with the formalities out of the way the
time had come to meet one of Australia's
lesser-known biological attractions
flow rooms are nocturnal they are
generally less sensitive to Red
wavelengths of light than they are white
or blue light
I guess to see them best we've got to
turn this off
[Applause]
meow talks a lot about a lot of things
sometimes he's hyping a mango that's
been altered to do your laundry and
other times he's promoting
hallucinogenated orgies to each his own
but without question meow's biohacking
enthusiasm has worked with Labs modeled
on this spot popping up all around the
country
prepare yourself Australia for the
phosphorescent revolution has begun
it's fluorescent behind me it was time
to leave Sydney and head south to the
bustling city of Melbourne
Melbourne lacks the surf culture of
Sydney but has plenty going on in a
sport mad country Melbourne is
considered the athletic Capital thanks
to its massive venues for Cricket rugby
and tennis
it's also something of a cultural
capital the elegant city gives off a
European charm with its huge Greek and
Italian communities a tram system and it
takes great pride in its laneways which
are alleys packed full of Street
graffiti and world-class restaurants one
after the other
if you're looking to eat your way
through Australia this is a good place
to start
The Artsy up-and-comer vibe to Melbourne
has had an impact on its Tech scene
people here have needed to think a bit
different to get attention and it's paid
off there's an argument to be made that
Melbourne may be Australia's most
promising Tech Hub at least in terms of
raw creativity
foreign
[Music]
the Undisputed king of Melbourne's
texian Bears this thesis out is rustling
kogan the founder and CEO of kogan.com
an online retailer that has changed the
way Australians shop we do about three
times more Revenue per employee than
Amazon he's a rich flamboyant
controversial workaholic who finds an
escape now and again at the Melbourne
Pier all right let's go catch some
Snapper okay
you must have been around like eight
years old when you moved here from from
Belarus or six years old
communism's falling apart my parents
decided to leave which I'm so thankful
for and came here with 90 in their
pockets
[Music]
Melbourne's housing projects and showed
an entrepreneur's Spirit right from the
start
as a kid he ran a golf ball cleaning
business a car wash and then a tech
Consulting operation
by the time he was 23 kogan had become
consumed with another Quest man's
Eternal hunt for an affordable flat
screen TV I thought you know I can't
afford it from the shops but let me
email some factories and I thought I'd
tell them that I want to order a hundred
thousand TVs and they'll get back to me
and then I'll ask for a sample and that
sample was going to be my TV
but when they started replying with all
of their quotes I saw very quickly that
there's a brilliant Market opportunity
here
to go direct to Chinese manufacturers to
buy TVs for a fraction of the going
price
to get the first batch of TVs kogan
maxed out a few credit cards and had to
borrow money from his friends you're on
this leg to just get a cheap TV and it
turns into a business idea yeah
[Music]
Australians had been slow to hop online
and local retailers had largely ignored
the web
kogan dragged the entire country online
and helped ignite an internet retail
boom
today kogan sells about 250 million
dollars of products per year and
wrestling wants to expand the brand
overseas and make kogan a household name
should we check if we slow Bae let's
have a look
not a single bot
what do you think should we keep trying
or should we drink beer
thanks man
is
people who keep telling me they feel
like Australia was a little bit late
through the tech business but now it's
turning this corner you know I can't
tell if I'm getting spun or or if there
really is kind of a corner being turned
look we went through a time in Australia
where our business leaders and
politicians were talking about how bad
online retail is because it's gonna it's
gonna cost a lot of jobs in the retail
industry luckily we're at a point now
where they're starting to realize that
Innovation is the future there's only a
certain amount of stuff you can dig out
of the ground our brain power and our
ideas are an unlimited resource and if
you can harness that one then you're
going to be a very rich Nation
foreign
City on the Move what you need is a
giant Ferris wheel
[Music]
the Melbourne star opened in 2008 and is
said to be the southern hemisphere's
only giant observation wheel
whatever that means
as far as big technology and big science
goes Melbourne can lay claim to some
stunning achievements
scientists here did pioneering work on
in vitro fertilization heart valve
replacement and Cochlear implants
and the big signs journey into our
bodies continues on at a place known as
the Australian synchrotron
the synchrotron cost 150 million dollars
to build and opened in 2007 in this
Melbourne suburb the building basically
functions like a giant x-ray machine
slash microscope it propels electrons at
incredible speeds and then manipulates
them with magnetic fields to produce a
brilliant form of light known as
synchrotron light this light can end up
being a million times brighter than the
Sun and can be tweaked by the building
to peer into a wide variety of objects
so far the synchrotron has been used to
examine plants and animals in fine
detail and to peer through the layers of
objects like old paintings
soon it may be used to
too good Andrew Ashley how you doing
nice to meet you nice to meet you Andrew
peel is a physicist and the director of
the synchrotron
he agreed to give me what's known as the
Greg Norman tour of the place that's a
sweet ride come aboard thank you
some of these beam lines that we're
driving past there are researchers using
these to do things like trying to cure
cancer different forms of disease a lot
of it's a bit like imagining a lock and
a key and if you can understand which
locks fit which Keys you can turn
diseases on and off you can stop cancer
in its tracks
recent anti-science Australian
governments have threatened to slash
funding for labs like this as a result
many top scientists have left the
country but in 2015 the synchrotron
lucked out and received 500 million
dollars in funding over the next 10
years
the hope is that this facility can make
money on its own by doing commercial
work yay science
to get a closer look at this machine
hello Daniel hello how are you I spoke
with Daniel hauserman a scientist here
who's looking at how the synchrotron can
diagnose and treat cancer we use x-ray
beam that our billion times brighter
than you would in the hospital
so in hospital it's safe you put your
chest in a second you get a chest x-ray
if you do a second without being here
you burn you're done you smoke there's a
hole in your chest okay
because of its unique construction the
Australian synchrotron can make large
beams 50 centimeters wide or about the
width of a human body this means that
the machine could be ideal for
turbocharged radiotherapy of tumors we
found that you can deliver doses which
are a Thousand Times Higher but more
targeted more targeted and less damage
to the healthy tissues okay so you could
say that thousand gray would kill a
human being if it was delivered in a
single short broad area when you make it
in micro beams it doesn't
it actually destroyed tumors much better
and Spares healthy tissue
it's not ready for human trials yet but
Daniel thinks people may soon be able to
make an appointment and have this
building go to work on your innards it
will be several years before we can
apply it to actually a patient therefore
the caveat if anyone watches your show
and then call us and say I want to bring
you my granddad because they can't treat
his cancer unfortunately with size sorry
we can't do it right now but maybe one
day but maybe in three or five years
yeah these optimistic notes reflect just
how hard Australian scientists must work
these days
justify their jobs and provide the
government with the hints that these
types of facilities May one day pay for
themselves
[Music]
but you know what's more fun than
anti-science bureaucrats
that would be dinosaurs
[Music]
welcome
to Jurassic Warehouse
[Music]
so this is stegosaur stegosaur um is for
a Jurassic world exhibition
this is our T-Rex she tends to steal the
show and dominate the workshop
I think one of those things is gonna eat
me
[Music]
Sonny tilders hails from Melbourne and
co-founded creature technology since its
birth in 2006 the company is specialized
in making giant robotic animals and has
ended up as one of the biggest
animatronics companies around
[Music]
the creature tea is made up of movies
special effects artists who needed work
during down periods
and their first project was a live show
called Walking with Dinosaurs that ended
up as the highest grossing touring event
in the world in 2010
they've been on high demand ever since
making rideable dragons a full-size King
Kong and cuddlier Creations like these
giant stuffed animals for the Sochi
Olympics Vladimir Putin still likes to
cuddle the bunny rabbit on the right
we didn't know where this is going to go
we thought we'd all go back to filming
TV but it grew out of this one show and
we realized that there was something in
this to bring that sort of film level
animatronics to a live audience
this is the indominus Rex at the moment
we're skinning the creature and the
girls are putting in some scales
each one of these creatures takes about
a year to create
every detail of the anatomy is built
from scratch including the eyeballs the
hydraulic skeleton and the lifelike
fabric skin so it's very similar to a
real creature it's got bones it's got
muscles it's got skin it's how they work
together is that's the trick really
to make the creatures seem more lifelike
the company's coders program nuanced
movement routines
but I'm not here to watch a computer
play with Dinosaurs
I'm here to take a dino out for a spin
so this is a voodoo rig so I'm actually
controlling the neck of this
Parasaurolophus now
this is all homegrown
yeah I mean we built these for our first
live show 10 years ago and this is our
Rusty workshop model
we'll never go yes okay
he's designed to be intuitive and smooth
and so you can take it through his whole
range and he will go where you want to
take him
[Music]
you're a little pet dinosaur yeah it's a
lot of fun
there were a couple of New Creations
coming to life in the creature Workshop
that we weren't allowed to show you
secrecy remains Paramount in the vicious
world of animatronics
it's safe to say though that the next
time a dinosaur giant plush bear or say
an alien greets you at an amusement park
then it came from this place on the
other side of the world
[Music]
Australia's done well for itself in
recent years
its Minds have churned out natural
resources that China has welcomed with
open wallets
there's the whole Ugg boot thing and the
local soap operas have kept the rest of
the world well stocked with attractive
entertainers
[Music]
it remains a mixed story
meow meow for example has decided to
form a startup in San Francisco because
it proved easier to raise money there
that said Australia still teams with
well-educated and motivated Engineers
coders and scientists
there are plenty of success stories now
for these youngsters to follow there's
also an undeniable urge for Australians
to make a go of it at home improve what
they're capable of
and if you fail the worst thing that can
happen is that you end up here looking
for another dash of courage in a beer
[Music]
Beach
[Music]
in New Zealand
this is a sheep and this is Gandalf most
people come to New Zealand to check out
the country's unmatched Beauty and to
get their Middle Earth fix and that
makes perfect sense
but on this trip
I'm hunting for something else
something less obvious
I'm after the Innovations being brought
to life Behind These doors
in these buildings
and in this studio
I'm heading out on a 400 mile journey
across New Zealand's North Island from
Auckland to Wellington to find the most
breathtaking inventions these kiwis have
cooked up we'll check out a mad
scientist
some Rockets
and an AI baby hi baby hi I'll either
warm your heart
or Leave You weeping over Humanity's
Grim future
[Music]
oh hello Sky Palace
oh
[Applause]
this is Auckland the home to 1.5 million
of New Zealand's 4.5 million people
people living outside of Auckland tend
to knock it as congested and hectic
meanwhile people living in Auckland
celebrate the way of life it offers oh
here's that gelato place everybody's
trying to go to
[Music]
he has a bustling food scene
there's a gorgeous Harbor surrounded by
fertile volcanic land
and those gannets and black sand beaches
you saw earlier
they're just a half hour drive from
downtown
this next part is going to sound cheesy
but honest to God it's true
Auckland is full of cheery optimistic
people to feel good when you're here
like you can do stuff big stuff
crazy stuff like say replicating human
consciousness on the inside of a
computer
face
it's our primary means of communication
[Music]
yeah
yeah but it's been untapped in terms of
a human computer interface how can I
help you
Wikipedia can express itself to you in a
human-like way which is emotional it's
cognitive no
no that's when you start getting to this
sort of interesting place
going to see an AI baby
on a sunny afternoon
the fella you meet next is a Madman in
the best possible way I'm gonna pull the
muscles which basically lower the brow
you smoke Sago a computer scientist at
the University of Auckland
so nose ringtone would be yeah let's do
your nose wrinkle extensions up
Mark became famous for building super
detailed simulations of the human body
and ended up winning a couple of Oscars
for his work on films like Avatar and
King Kong so let's go here and you know
foreign
these days Mark is how to put this
trying to reverse engineer the human
brain he's built a series of simulations
around how the human face moves how we
express emotion and how our neurons fire
we're trying to build a computer which
has experiences can imagine and
basically it has its own sort of
existence in a way so now what we're
going to do is I'm going to run baby x
thank you what we're building here is a
computer that can learn
so this is baby she's sort of looking at
us and hearing us so if I make a loud
noise and I should get a fright this is
what she can see so you can see my face
here
all right so she's not copying my smash
she's responding to me and now this is
her little first baby's first word
so you can pick a pick a page you know
show her something but she has to be
looking at it so get her attention hi
baby hi hi hi
what do you see
what's this
puppy puppy okay good what's that baby
this is because we're in New Zealand
you've got to share your sheep yeah I'll
give her the word yeah yeah hi baby hi
what do you see baby
sheep very good baby
and the long-term goals is can we create
a confrontational model of Consciousness
because then you go okay the computer
model has just become conscious of
something is that thought or not
now all the facial expressions
everything's driven by neural Nets so as
we look around what I'm going to do is
now is remove her face basically and so
this is what's driving in the background
and so what you're looking at now these
are all the connections lighting up
right as the baby's doing stuff and this
is like a simulation of what would be
happening a person's brain yeah because
if you're going to make a character
biological and behave naturally then
you've got to use a natural model so
that's the sort of what's going on
inside babyings
now we take this stuff and we now
connect it to cognitive Computing
systems so you've got biological neural
networks connected to artificial
intelligence models and the potential
for that's enormous that's where the
future is probably going to be and maybe
[Music]
there's a term new zealanders have for
possessed inventor types like Mark
they're part of the country's number
eight wire culture
like so many things here the story of
number eight wire goes back to those
sheets Farmers used to make their fences
out of eight wire gauge metal
then they started to use the wire to fix
just about any problem on the farm over
time a number eight wire mythology
evolved to capture the can-do spirit of
people living in a remote place and of a
people who had to solve problems in any
clever way they could
but while new zealanders remained fond
of the eight wire idea there's an
undeniable sense that the country is
ready to level up
it's time to start inventing with more
purpose and polish
the gritty garage Workshop is giving way
to this
this a pristine mad scientist lab that
looks like it could be for sale in an
Apple Store
Avery embodies kiwi ingenuity
he's a prolific scientist and inventor
sir Avery this is Ashley Vance he made a
fortune in the pharmaceutical industry
and then decided to dedicate his life to
helping the world's poorest people hence
the sir all right this way it's a cool
house right because those are the magic
wardrobe
I followed sir Avery through a wardrobe
door into his garage slash lab where he
creates his objects
I noticed everything in the house is
white that you're wearing white yeah
yeah yeah I'm in a bit like Steve Jobs I
have two dresses I have black for winter
and white for summer but the thing is
that I know that I've got 4795 days left
to live how do you know that well
because I've done the algorithm analysis
of somebody my age born at my time how
much Chardonnay I drink all that sort of
so I know what I'm going to do with the
next 10 years of my life failure is
really just for people are unprepared
you don't waste time on things that
aren't going to get you to where you
need to go in things like clothes
so Avery is well known for taking
complicated medical devices and making
them simple cheap and durable
did you make this in here yeah yeah and
this is your Workshop lab everything
okay
currently he's working on this incubator
this really is a live pod because it's
almost like you know something that
Superman would be happy to be in and the
shape of it is very much more about
getting even air distribution and trying
to make it look cool
the life pod cost two thousand dollars
versus forty thousand dollars for
typical incubators the hope is that it
could save thousands of lives each year
I'll show you this is really cool and
this is oh my God it's pretty pretty
ugly he also has this giant block of
frozen chicken slurry as a way to
amplify the nutritional value of trash
meat so that's after Kentucky Fried have
taken all their bits the legs and the
chest meat they make it into this stuff
chicken slurry because I have a spoonful
of that later
so every mixes the trash meat with of
all things kiwi this breaks it down into
the basic amino acids so your body can
absorb the nutrients more easily it's
aimed at helping malnourished children
if you take that then you're going to
get instant energy and you don't need to
digest it go straight across your gut
this will save millions and millions of
kids alive
you know Einstein said the most elegant
solution is always the most simplest and
Kiwis have a very practical way of doing
things
if you take away the noise that you have
often with things like Silicon Valley
and you just have a bunch of guys in
sheds with a lathe and a few bits and
pieces they come up with stuff that
nobody else has thought of
[Music]
I think new zealanders don't think big
enough
they don't go after the really big
problems and the big billion dollar
ideas
[Music]
I started building Rockets when I was at
school
[Music]
and the very first rocket that I built I
ended up putting on a bicycle
most rocket companies are started by
wealthy governments and billionaires
rocket lab was started in 2007 by this
maniac
Peter Beck
Peter is one of the most capable people
on the planet
[Music]
he never went to college opting instead
to hone his own engineering craft in the
garage and machine shops uh I don't know
why Rockets make me so happy
now he wants to make it much easier and
cheaper to put small satellites into
space if you had a satellite on your lap
right now in one week I can have that on
orbit moreover I can have that on all
but an auto magnitude less cost than any
other way of getting it there
the first rocket launch will take place
later this year
wow this is the first one that's going
to go up yep
commercial customers have already signed
up and there's a two-year waiting list
how much are you going to charge per
flight we're 4.9 million dollars okay
4.9 million dollars might seem like a
lot but it's actually a remarkable
figure and liftoff of the Falcon 9
rocket and dragon the cheapest way to
get to space today is on one of Elon
musk's Rockets from SpaceX and that
costs 60 million dollars per trip
rocket Labs prices would open space to a
whole new set of customers including
scientists and businesses and in effect
democratize space
this is what the Aerospace world has
dreamed of for decades this is the
second stage second stage yeah you can
lift it up yep
you rolled your eyes a little bit at
this eight wire thing why is that if
someone sees you know rocket lab as a
number eight wire company they'll get
escorted off the site they're just gone
because number eight why it's about sort
of bodging stuff together to make it
work and that's really not what new
zealanders have evolved to it's about
really high-tech Innovation and doing
really really clever things
[Music]
with launch day approaching the pressure
is on
today they're running an engine test at
a site near the Auckland Airport it's
the worst case scenario it flies out
blows up in the best case is how does it
deal
ing a company is half yeah building a
rocket company damn near insane I
hitched a ride with Peter to the test
site and arrived just in time for
countdown three two wow
the engine test was successful but
there's still a ways to go what does it
feel like in your gut with that
countdown clock in the office and
everything that comes with sleep much
that's probably the best answer for that
question with a bit of luck Peter will
maintain his sanity through 2017.
that's when rocket lab plans to start
flying for paying customers
this is a tiny company of a hundred
people that will have bested entire
nations and firmly put New Zealand's
stamp on the world
that's not eight wire culture that's
just flat out amazing
and with that it's now time to leave
Auckland and journey to Middle Earth
we could have flown from Auckland to
Wellington and it would have taken an
hour but we wanted to be basted in
Hobbit fives we had to see the land
[Music]
to your laptop
New Zealand is everything they said it
would be
plus Burger Rose it smells like beef it
tastes like pork grind if aliens ever
visit Earth and want to see what it has
to offer their first stop would have to
be New Zealand
it's like a sampler platter of
Landscapes Rolling Hills deserts Plains
tropical forests whizzing by one after
another
for now
thanks for listening laptop love Ashley
[Music]
three hours outside of Auckland
we made a pit stop and a hot spring
[Music]
all the signs leading into this place
warn you that you'll get meningitis if
you stick your head underwater
I'm hoping that I live after this
relaxing afternoon
[Music]
now the boy I learned about the
meningitis the more afraid I am that I
have the meningitis
you know you come to New Zealand and
it's all Haywire culture you can send up
Rockets actually you know you dunk your
head underwater then you're dead so
lesson
this mighty's cool
[Music]
just reminds me of all the flipping her
out of my brain
[Music]
welcome to a rainy and famously windy
Wellington
New Zealand's capital city and home to a
thriving film industry
director Peter Jackson is the local Boy
made good he famously made Lord of the
Rings here and then shot past being a
one-hit wonder
Peter has created an entire movie
industry based around his Film
Production Company WETA
[Music]
like Hollywood but without any of the
glitz and glamor Studio lots and sound
stages are dull and unmarked
they're tucked into a quiet suburb
called Miramar
WETA has started to expand into virtual
reality and I was invited to take a look
at their first VR movie a scene from The
Hobbit where smog wakes up from a nap
ice
level
you said it wasn't going to be Friday
in the shadows
it's crazy man I mean you feel like real
emotions when you see it that's the nice
thing for you are you get people get
such a much more emotional experience
than seeing something like in a video
game or whatever and I think that's kind
of where the space we're in the content
generation and the custom technology on
the software side to kind of enable
these these high-end experiences
[Music]
foreign
next the studio where they filmed Lord
of the Rings I just want to grab that
and have a look around where I got a
crash course in motion capture
filmmaking using Peter Jackson's very
own custom-made camera
which isn't really a camera but more of
a device to place a director in a
virtual world there's a screen on the
top that shows a rough version of the
final Graphics while dozens of sensors
around the room record all of the
camera's movements all you've got to do
is yell action yep they'll do this stuff
and you say cut like any other film
action
inside
yes yes
okay too late you've got to run for
safety this Tech brings a human element
back to green screen filmmaking
it's more tactile
it makes the director actually feel like
he's shooting the film again all right
cut
a really good split thanks
wetta became an industry of its own and
after the success of Lord of the Rings
spawn startups that are their own mini
wettest I'm Ashley
on my last stop I went to one of these
startups Aid eye Studios
it's a VR company that is recording
people in three dimensions to bring them
into virtual reality
[Music]
the difference from looking at a video
to seeing a hologram that looks just
like the real thing is so powerful Ada
is developing software that will bring
VR to the masses
the day you can capture a loved one in
Virtual space is almost here
[Music]
we'll show you some experiences where
we've captured some humans with
off-the-shelf cameras it feels like
you're in the room with a person can I
check it out sure
all right so you can see the room yep
all right so oh hello we create a
virtual environment but then we capture
a very lifelike motion of the cloth and
the human performance and we can compose
those together so you've been at what uh
we're used to making these CGI fantastic
creatures but it just wouldn't work for
a normal person to have to you don't
want to drop a visual effects Hollywood
production budget just to record your
child experiencing their first steps
right and as we saw that these headsets
were coming along there was no clear
efficient cheap scalable solution to
capture reality and to author
experiences at a scale and out of
realism and at a pace that would create
a similar sort of content database for
people to enjoy let's see how your view
of heights is so this is gonna be like a
movie oh my God
that's crazy because I'm sort of like
afraid of heights usually
oh
I mean I felt like I was gonna like walk
off a cliff that was really frightening
although I was a bit skeptical it was
time to scan myself
so I could meet the virtual Ashley
which way do I look like this way you
don't have to look anywhere okay you're
captured from from all sides so have fun
and I just have to stay in the circle
pretty much I was surrounded by 30
cameras all perfectly spaced and
measured it was like an OCD Paparazzi
I'm Ashley Vance except I'm not really
Ashley Vance I'm a digital asset that's
being made at 8i Studios
and then in post they put together all
those different angles to make a final
3D version of me if you want to get
really nerdy this is called volumetric
cinematography just for the Nerds
hands and pockets
hands and pockets that's my little
virtual friends
so I get to see my virtual self yeah
you've seen yourself many many times in
2D video so I think it would be
underwhelmed I think I'm just gonna see
what I always look like in the mirror I
don't know why seeing like a 3D version
of yourself would be a big deal I would
much rather be chased by smog so I can
just walk around now yeah
that's kind of strange
the detail's insane I mean you can see
like whiskers right yeah I mean the
cameras are just that good and we're
looking to increase that resolution as
well give yourself a smooch
[Laughter]
step into yourself oh duh that is crazy
whoa I also did not know where I was in
the room
so I thought it would be really janky
and I mean it is lifelike you know and
so that I guess was the biggest surprise
for me so you think people are going to
want VR to be human I've got two boys
and they grow up so quick and it's like
oh man if you could just remember how
they talked and their gestures and the
funny things they said that would be
really cool
the thing about New Zealand its economy
today depends on sheep cows and tourists
and everyone knows that needs to change
technology is the country's future
thanks to companies like rocket lab
rexbiotics and ADI the change is already
underway
foreign investors have started to pour
money into New Zealand and Engineers are
staying at home because there are good
jobs to be had
if you're an outsider looking to come
here well why not the scenery is
breathtaking the weather is good and the
eight wire days have passed
New Zealand is taking on some of the
hardest problems in the industry
it's working on the technology of the
Absurd
a
I told her
[Applause]
a trip to Chile's High Desert is the
perfect excuse to hang with someone like
Magdalena
she's a shaman who for a reasonable fee
offers up a soul cleanse
spirit is healed as your brain melts
time is an illusion
you know that
we all know
after the ceremonial stripping of the
Gringo and whatever this is
Magdalena forces me to drink an ungodly
amount of water
start a new relation with water so you
will be clean okay
then she Burns me
[Music]
into my wounds she pours something
called combo which is a secretion that
comes from a very poisonous Amazonian
tree frog
[Applause]
is an illusion water is life
and that's when the Frog Juice really
kicked in
[Music]
there was the desert
it was cruel and then it was kind
[Music]
there were huge telescopes nestled up
against the heavens
there were strange gurgling Pools full
of minerals
there was a bustling City and a chair I
could control with my mind
it was a grand vision of what Chile had
to offer and what needed to be explored
science says that the Atacama Desert is
the driest place in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the desert Plateau is about 10 000 feet
above sea level
the Days Run extremely hot
and the nights get extremely cold
it turns out that this hellscape is the
perfect place to build a telescope
the lack of moisture in the air the view
of the stars is practically unobstructed
[Music]
economical projects in the world
[Music]
so we're just 500 meters now from the
top of the site
I do feel a little bit light-headed
already
[Music]
almost telescopes sit at nearly 17 000
feet the same elevation as Everest Base
Camp so it's cold windy and difficult to
breathe
[Music]
telescopes
the middle of nowhere with the United
States Japan and Europe footing most of
the bill
and for that kind of money they didn't
just get a garden variety optical
telescope
they got something special
I tracked down almost kindly head
mechanic Fabiola to get a better
understanding of how this place works
when you're in Santiago and you go out
to dinner with somebody how do you
explain to them how the telescope works
um
we did not
come you look on the sky and that's what
you see yeah
with Alma whatever you don't see with
your eyes whatever is black that is a
lot you see with Alma
Alma sees in what's
range of the electromagnetic spectrum
far beyond the visible range seen by
optical telescopes and the human eye
armed with this superhuman Vision Alma
can unveil all kinds of magical stuff in
the universe that would have been
invisible before
to get an idea of what wonders Alma is
finding in space I went to the control
center where I met this very tall man at
one time when I was in graduate school I
was supposedly the tallest astronomer
who'd ever lived younger generation that
was taller so I'm not sure that's still
true
Richard Simon and his fellow astronomers
are using Alma to look for the origins
of stars life and the universe itself
with Alma they're able to see the cosmos
in more detail than ever before
when I was looking at the work that you
guys do you could spot even sugar
molecule near a star that's somewhere
off in the Milky Way we can detect all
kinds of different molecules think of
Alma as a huge chemical sniffer so we
can start to understand how stars form
how planets form how did we wind up with
water to Sport Life
The Surreal images Alma creates have
revealed Earth-like exoplanets a comet
nursery and galaxies at the edge of the
known universe
in the not so distant future they could
also help answer the question of whether
we're not alone
[Music]
one of the small moans of Saturn and
salatus has geysers of water vapor and
other materials coming out and it's
possible with Alma to actually look at
that and try to see some of the
chemistry that's going on what is inside
that moon what is blasting out into
space are there complicated organic
molecules I suspect that we will learn a
lot more about the chemistry of life and
the possibilities for life in very
strange places even here in our own
solar system
keep watching the skies You Beautiful
nerds
[Music]
it's not all dusty highways and infinite
Vistas in the Chilean desert there's big
Tech and big fun to be had as well
find the fun you just need to look for
the Oasis the town of San Pedro de
aracama
[Music]
this is one of the world's most remote
tourist hot spots
[Music]
the magnet for dirty hippies and chilled
out dogs
[Music]
choose to vacation at 8 000 feet in the
desert
well there are glorious geysers that
demand to be roamed
for sand dunes to surf
and there are huge watering holes that
no one can explain
[Music]
thank you
oddly enough there's big business out in
the Atacama too
more solar radiation reaches this desert
than anywhere else in the world
this makes it the perfect place to build
massive solar panel Farms
if you stop by for a visit they'll put
you to work washing the panels
[Music]
energy is that it needs to be stored
I like that
[Music]
and the Atacama happens to have an
answer for that too
Chile is one of the world's leading
producers of lithium the stuff that goes
into all of our smartphone laptop and
electric car batteries
and to see how lithium is pulled from
the earth I went to visit the operations
of the mining Giant sqm
hello Ashley how you doing finally here
my guide through the mines is Alejandro
Bucher
local engineer who has spent years
working in the great void
something like a lithium-ion battery and
a laptop or even a Tesla with thousands
of batteries it's what like a spoonful
of lithium that would go into those
batteries uh if you would say in a Nike
pad or in a cell phone you could have
something like a spoonful in a car you
could have maybe 10 to 15 kilos of
lithium
it's the nearby Andes mountains that
make these mines possible
over millions of years minerals from the
mountains leach into the ground
then they collect together and form huge
salt beds rich in lithium sulfate
potassium and boron
companies like sqm pump water up through
the beds and store the mineral-rich
liquid in large ponds
from there it's up to the Sun to do its
thing and evaporate away the water
the minerals and salt behind
and nowhere evaporates better than Chile
[Applause]
for the first part of the pond operation
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a lot of ponds
those are pretty
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first pond
you can see the salts forming
in the surface
that's gotta be crazy because you
already have the harsh heat and cold and
then you have all this salt just pouring
around these pickup trucks suffer a lot
but the other equipment we made them
from a special steel that really works
good here
and now we're moving to the lithium
fonts that are only two of the 44
million square meters that we have here
[Music]
we made it so we can experience what is
a little brain
when we have it in the big ponds we
cannot sample it
so we made this little pond
what exactly is this stuff this is
magnesium chloride magnesium chloride
it's a magnesium that we need to get rid
of for being able to produce the lithium
in the plant okay we will only send on
the track the liquid just the liquid
just the liquid okay so this is lithium
what are the odds that some part of this
is in my smartphone I couldn't guarantee
it but it's pretty sure that almost 100
sure that part of your smartphone went
through this point at some point it's a
past at some point this is smartphone
smartphone juice yeah
you guys must be excited the Teslas are
selling well and that everybody's
getting into watching cars now it's very
interesting but it it puts a lot of
pressure on us so we will more than
double our capacity probably in four
years
[Music]
foreign
may have the largest lithium deposits in
the world but it started to fall behind
countries like Australia and China when
it comes to production
and in China it's a One-Stop shop with
the mining and Battery production
happening together
[Music]
Chilean companies have been unwilling to
take maybe you could make the batteries
here in Chile well for me it would be
excellent but the company we're experts
in hybrid geology we're expert in mining
we're expert in producing lithium
if we put us to produce batteries we're
probably not going to do it well
[Music]
tense lately between the mines and the
Chilean government
[Music]
is on lithium production and they've
also been
safe
some politicos were accused of taking
bribes from the mines
[Music]
[Applause]
nearby lagoons that feed these flocks of
stunning flamingos what we do here has
absolutely no impact to the flamingos
but we're still responsible of what's
happening with them
we need to do counting of the flamingos
every year
they identify them by the feathers on
the tail so they they can differentiate
every flamingo
miners here work for a week and then
take a week off because of the dry hot
salty conditions
but there are some on-the-job perks the
sunsets here are every day amazing you
have all these different colors that
only women know the names
every day and you don't get tired of
that it's really beautiful
[Music]
Alejandro has a point
much about the colors that only women
apparently know but about the beauty of
the minds
these odd Marvels make the modern world
run
let Tesla's Flamingo breeding program
begin
[Music]
Chileans like to hold Santiago up as a
symbol of everything they've done right
[Music]
prosperous
and there's all that you would want from
a capital city clinging to the bottom of
the globe
[Music]
sure you can get roped into the
occasional
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
but here they say it's more refined and
nothing says refinement like a foot long
Coney mayonnaise definitely a
questionable choice
this Capital built with mineral wealth
and struggling with its Fallout is
looking for new ways to survive in a
changing environment
foreign
[Music]
with the touch of a button
Hector made a fortune as an engineer but
now works full time on his freshwater
system what propelled you to think up
this project
Asana
[Music]
[Music]
to use this machine at home yes okay and
and your daughter uses this every day uh
they complete my family
[Music]
is
[Music]
this technology having uses far beyond
his family
this freshwater machine feeds off
humidity in the air it pulls in water
particles through a vent and then
basically forms a rain cloud inside the
machine
a series of filters purify the water
collect it and then pristine H2O flows
out of the faucet
[Music]
so I can drink it yeah
[Music]
it's no problem
with delicious
right now one magic water machine costs
about 1600 bucks but he wants to shrink
the price and its size to something like
a backpack
as he perfects the design he's installed
his machines in Chile's dry north
[Music]
um
actor distilled the idea for fresh water
inside an incubator funded by some of
Santiago's wealthiest people foreign
it's called the idea Factory or if for
those into the whole brevity thing
they support Tech with a do-good or bent
politicians stopped by the schmooze kids
get a chance to learn it's not a factory
designed to build the next Google or
Facebook it focuses on things for Chile
in South America
and they've got hyper local branches
hidden in unexpected corners of Santiago
there are Tech incubators all over the
world but you won't find many in a
neighborhood like this if has another
building here that's been set up to
inspire local youngsters and give
budding inventors a helping hand
[Music]
here in recoletta things are a bit more
lively than in Palo Alto
[Music]
showed up on a demo day when kids from
the neighborhood pour through the gates
to check out ifs gadgets
Andy but nothing beat this hello robot
the other video conferencing robot on a
stick
but this one is basically lethal
that's so cool
all of the gadgets come from this man
Rodrigo quivero he's something of a
local celebrity and has Kanye West's
levels of passion is
[Music]
necessary
foreign
[Music]
Army and then an engineer until he had a
revelation and became a robotics
entrepreneur
his most inspired invention is this
wheelchair people can control it by
tilting their head or making a gesture
soon Rodrigo hopes it'll move by thought
Alone by reading impulses from a
brainwave monitor
[Music]
Rodrigo's helpers were surprisingly
gentle as they gave me the power of
telekinesis
[Music]
that's how I turn it on three blinks
it's like a genie
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and that was the perfect ending to a
magical trip
Chile will always have a special place
in my subconscious
[Music]
When I close my eyes at night I can
still hear my Shaman Magdalena singing
and see her desert compound
foreign
but you know in a good way
[Music]
of all my trips around the world this
year this one was a proper Adventure
there's a mystical quality to Chile and
it only gets more profound as your body
dries out and your brain loses oxygen
as for the tech Chile has the big stuff
down
it has embraced the weirdness of the
land and tried to make the most out of
it
if the startups in Santiago can tap into
that same Spirit then Chile has a bright
future ahead
after that where the poison really got
to me
[Music]